so I'm going to read two passages from
the book one just detecting the the
difference in the personalities between
prisoners and the first one is ha genus
Watson I often think about this because
well I'll read it but he this was the 80
year old and it was at the end of our
session at Guantanamo as the meeting
ended it was obvious that the old man
was in pain his legs hurt he tried to
stand and stretch them he pushed hard
against the tabletop with his palms
trying to lift his weight I left to
aside and helps him stand he gripped the
edge of the table for balance and exhale
deeply a few moments later I helped him
sit back down as we started collecting
our things to go I turned back to the
straw who was watching us gather up the
pizza boxes and pistachio shells and
unfinished baklava the military didn't
allow any food to be left with the
detainee so we had to take any leftovers
with us but Jay my child tell your
mother and your father that an old man
with a white beard sends his salaams he
said I responded with the customary
reply waalaikumussalam and may peace
also be upon you I adjusted my shell one
last time and glanced at him he was
quiet for a moment then he opened his
heavy arms to me and I embraced him he
pushed my head into his white prison
uniform and for several moments prayed
for me as Peter watched inshallah God
willing you will find a home that makes
you happy in sha Allah you will be a
mother one day inshallah you will always
have a family that will protect you
inshallah you will finish law school and
continue to help us inshallah you will
make the world proud then he patted my
back you were a great woman in may Allah
make you greater finally he let me go
and ask me to say prayers for him of
course I promised every day so the point
I read that passage because here was
this man who is has nothing he didn't
have his freedom his help he was kept in
a cage like that I wouldn't put my dog
in and yet in His goodness of spirit
he started praying for me and I just
thought that spoke volumes about who he
was the second passage that I'd like to
read is about taj muhammad and taj
muhammad was the complete opposite of
how jeana's throughout he was just
easier to meet but here is his passage i
know it's not good to play favorites but
i couldn't help it of all the detainees
we worked with I most look forward to
the meetings with taj muhammad number 9
02 he was a 27 year old goat herd from
Kunar afghanistan who who formed crushes
on his female interrogators and taught
himself perfect english in his four
years at Guantanamo it's not that I like
Taj better than the other detainees
they're all different but he was easy to
talk to and he made me laugh I felt
sorry for hygiene aswath who was old and
sick and for always Thomas obey because
he was so polite but Taj was my age and
loaded with personality unlike the
others he really came across as
vulnerable he was highly opinionated and
very sarcastic even his misogyny was
somehow comical I'm sure he would have
gotten on my nerves if I'd spent more
time listening to his sarcastic
wisecracks but in our limited contact he
was pure entertainment in our meetings
with Paul Raskin of the Miami federal
defenders Tasha's attention was always
drawn to written English he would sound
out the lettering on coffee cups and
napkins when legal papers were put on
the table he would win when legal papers
were put on the table he would
immediately start reading under his
breath he asked us repeatedly to bring
him a pesto English dictionary so that
he could improve his English over
several months he had compiled and
memorize a list of almost 1,000 English
words but during a routine search the
guards had found and confiscated his
neatly written glossary when Paul told
him it was unlikely that he'd be given
it permission to bring him a book Todd
looked unhappy if you can't bring me a
book how do you plan on getting me out
of here he said even the interrogators
give us magazines I asked what kind of
magazines playboy he said I'd heard the
same from guards at the Clipper club who
said that lots of detainees made
associations between American women
based on what they saw in soft core
men's magazine maxim some of the guards
help that along it seemed at the
beginning of my second meeting with Taj
he pulled out a small piece of creased
white paper and handed it to me I told
the guards that the girl who speaks
Pashto is coming and asked them to make
a list of words so you could translate
them for me he said my jaw dropped as I
scanned the list what does it say Taj
asked tell me the first word on bliss
was bestiality the second was pedophile
the third was intercourse and the fourth
was Horning I think those soldiers have
played a little trick on you and me ice
marked tell me he persisted what did
they write I don't know how to say these
words in Pashto I responded i learned
pesto from my parents Hodges eyes
widened okay just tell me one of the
words he insisted I don't know them I
said then tell me what it means I
scanned the words again beastiality
means showing Mina affection or love to
one of the goats you tend I said smiling
but it's not a good sort of Mina taged
lata to laugh he got the picture he
grabbed a pen from the table and
scribbled something in Pashto next to
the word that's when I realized he'd
probably known the nature of his
vocabulary lessons all along